David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 24th, at Deutsches Museum, the UNRRA University. We are going to interview now a Polish-Jewish girl, a student, Miss Roma Tcharna—...Tcharnabroda, of whom...who has lost both of her legs in a concentration camp. That is, she suffered from frozen legs, and they were amputated three days after the Americans came to liberate them. We are going to...I am passing the microphone to Roma.
David Boder: [In German] Also Fräulein, sind Sie Fräulein oder Frau?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Frau.
David Boder: Frau. Ist Ihr Mann hier?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Verloren.
David Boder: Sie haben Ihren Mann verloren? Also sind Sie Witwe?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Also Frau Tcharnabroda, wollen Sie mir sagen, wo Sie waren und was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat?
Roma Tcharnabroda: 1939 war ich in Polen, dann wie die Deutschen haben sich genähert—mein Mann war kriegsverpflichtet und war Arzt—so hat man ihn gerufen zum Militär.
David Boder: In welcher Stadt in Polen waren Sie?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Kielce.
David Boder: Kielce?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Ist das die Stadt wo jetzt das Programm war?
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Weiter...dann ist mein Mann...er ist mit dem Militär weg, aber man hat ihn nicht eingezogen, sondern er hat einen Befehl bekommen in die Richtung nach Osten zu ziehen. Ich als Schwester, weil wir haben das Gymnasium kurz beendigt.
David Boder: Sie waren auch eine Krankenschwester?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, das war nur, hm, hm, vom Gymnasium, nur vom Training im Gymnasium beendet.
David Boder: Ja, aber als Krankenschwester?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, aber die können nur in Notwendigkeit eingezogen werden.
David Boder: Ja, also Krankenschwester-Gehilfinnen.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, Gehilfin.
David Boder: Ja, Kadett Nurse?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, also wir sind beide nach Osten gefahren—in Richtung von Osten nach Lemberg.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie auch jiddisch?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Sehr schlecht [lacht etwas]?
David Boder: . . . aber doch deutsch?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja! Also in die Richtung nach Rovno. Und dann von Rovno—da sind dann schon die Russen gekommen—und dann sind wir nach Lemberg gefahren und von 1939 bis 1941 war ich unter die Herrschaft von den Russen—in Lemberg.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: 1941 sind die Deutschen nach Lemberg gekommen. Ich habe alle Programme mit gemacht, die in Lemberg stattgefunden haben, das heißt vom ersten Tag wenn sie sind gekommen und, hm, Brzezinski, das Gefängnis, das bekannte Gefängnis aufgemacht. Die Deutschen haben festgestellt, dass dort viele, viele Leichen sind und dass die Bolschewisten bevor sie sind heraus gekommen, haben ganze [unverständlich] gemacht, das heißt sie haben sehr viele, zum Beispiel: Beine abgeschnitten, und so weiter.
David Boder: Das haben die Bolschewisten getan?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das haben die Deutschen gesagt, dass die Bolschewisten haben das getan.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, aber die Kommission von die Ärzte, von polnischen und ukrainischen Ärzte, die mit gekommen sind mit den Deutschen in das Gefängnis Brzezinski, haben eine Bemerkung gemacht, dass die Leichen, bei den Leichen...sieht man kein Blut nicht bei den abgeschnittenen Beinen. Man hat eine ganz komische Situation gesehen, dass wenn man bei Lebendigen abschneidet einen Teil vom Körper, sieht man noch Blut. Und bei diesen Leuten hat man kein Blut gesehen also wahrscheinlich hat man das erst nach dem Tode arrangiert.
David Boder: Und wer waren die Toten da?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Toten das waren Gefangene, die zurück geblieben sind in dem Gefängnis, wenn die Bolschewisten heraus gezogen sind.
David Boder: Und wer hat sie dann erschossen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Diese ermordet, ermordet—wahrscheinlich die Deutschen selbst.
David Boder: Nun ja, wenn die Deutschen sie selbst ermordet haben, dann konnten sie doch die Füße und Hände nicht sofort abschneiden, dann würde doch Blut dort gewesen sein.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, es ist möglich, dass die Bomben und die, die Splitter von Granaten herein gefallen sind—damals wenn die Bolschewisten herausgezogen sind und während dem Kämpfen könnte das damals auch passieren.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, also dass sie das damals arrangiert haben, war ganz klar.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also damals auch für Vergeltung hat man [unverständlich] als Juden, natürlich...
David Boder: Ja?
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . die Juden müssen zahlen.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und damals waren die erste Proben, dass man hat Juden hat weggeschleppt nach Belzec, die ersten Vernichtungslager waren damals eingerichtet. Man hat noch keine Ahnung...
David Boder: Ja?
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . von Krematorien gehabt.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie mir das alles jetzt erzählen, wie es Sie gegangen ist, wie es Ihnen...gegangen ist
Roma Tcharnabroda: Mir.
David Boder: Wie es IHNEN gegangen ist, was Ihnen passiert ist, wie die Deutschen...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also 1941, wie die Deutschen sind gekommen, war ich im Lager auf der Yanovska Strasse—Arbeitslager...
David Boder: Also die Deutschen haben Sie in ein...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja,in Arbeitslager eingezogen. Von dort bin ich weg...
David Boder: Wo war Ihr Mann?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Mein Mann war auch in Lemberg und war auch im Arbeitslager.
David Boder: Bitte weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dann habe ich...
David Boder: Im selben Lager?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Im selben Lager—das war ein Arbeitslager.
David Boder: Haben Sie ihn sehen können?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, damals konnte ich ihn noch sehen.
David Boder: Bitte weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dann bin ich fort gelaufen...von diesem Arbeitslager und mein Mann auch und wir sind in schwarz in den General Gouvernat gekommen.
David Boder: Was heißt das „schwarz“?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Schwarz—das heißt ohne Erlaubnis von den deutschen Behörden.
David Boder: Wo sind Sie hin gekommen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: In der Nähe von Kielce, eine kleine Stadt—nach Njele.
David Boder: Ja. Warum haben Sie das gesagt „ General Gouvernat“?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Weil damals war schon die Benennung [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja, weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und dann von dem Gouvernat...war ich einige Monat in dem General Gouvernat, das war am Ende 1942, 1942 und dann hat es angefangen mit diesen Auslieferungen.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Meine polnischen Freunde...wie Dinge angefangen haben in Warschau, da sind meine polnischen Freunde zu mir gekommen und haben gesagt: „Ihr geht alle auf Schmelz.“
David Boder: Die waren in Warschau?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, ich war in einer kleinen Stadt in der Kielce Umgebung
David Boder: Und was haben Ihre polnischen Freunde gesagt? Ihr geht alle...“
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Juden von Warschau gehen alle auf Schmelz.
David Boder: Und was heißt das „Schmelz“?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Schmelz, das ist eine deutsche Benennung—alle in Ofen rein.
David Boder: Aha.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Juden von Warschau haben noch nichts genau gewusst, aber diese...
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: haben schon gewusst die Polen, weil man wusste, dass man [unverständlich] die eigentlichen Transporte von den Juden. Also ich habe arische Papiere bekommen und ich bin nach Warschau geflüchtet. Ich war auf arischer Seite bis Ende 1942 und dann...
David Boder: Mit arischer Seite meinen Sie, das heißt ‚outside’...außen...
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . außerhalb vom Ghetto.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Am Ende 1942 war ich gezwungen ins Ghetto rein zu gehen.
David Boder: Wieso, wenn Sie arische Papiere hatten?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja,...weil es war eine ganz besondere Schichte in der polnischen Gesellschaft, die..., die sich damit beschäftigt hat, die Juden auszuliefern, ganz einfach.
David Boder: Bitte weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, und dann war ich gezwungen ganz einfach, weil man hat mir alles geraubt und ich war gezwungen ins Ghetto zu gehen.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ohne einen Groschen natürlich. Das war nach der so genannten ersten Aussiedlung in Warschau. Das Warschauer Ghetto war schon damals sehr klein. Nach den Statistiken hat es fünfzig tausend (50.000) Juden noch gehabt. Aber diese waren noch...manche waren noch versteckt und es waren wahrscheinlich mehr. Ich hab mitgemacht die zweite Auslieferung 1943 im Januar. Damals war auch die so genannte „Werte Erfassung“, das war eine deutsche Firma, die hat sich damit beschäftigt mit alle, mit allen Sachen, die von den Juden zurück geblieben sind, alles zu sortieren...
David Boder: Was sind Werte...?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Werte Erfassung.
David Boder: Werte...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Erfassung.
David Boder: Erfassung
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Das war eine deutsche Firma?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. Und die Juden mussten dort arbeiten. Durch Zufall habe ich in dieser Firma gearbeitet.
David Boder: Und was hat man dort getan?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Was man hat getan, man hat sortiert , hm, Bettwäsche und diese Wäsche und diese Wäsche, jedes...
David Boder: Und wo hat man das bekommen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Wo? Im Ghetto selbst, das war so ein großes Magazin von all diesen zurück gebliebenen Sachen.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also, dort habe ich die zweite Auslieferung mit gemacht. Es sind noch Leute in Warschau geblieben. Darf ich erzählen von diese arme Leute, die ich dort gesehen...
David Boder: Ja, ja, wenn Sie sie gesehen haben, dann sollen Sie erzählen.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also...während der Aussiedlung selbst hat man Truppen von uns genommen für Arbeit. Das heißt, ich bin in ein Zimmer gekommen, wo eine alte Frau auf dem Bett lag. In der Hand hat sie eine Karte gehabt, sie wollte...sie wollte wahrscheinlich zeigen, dass sie irgendwo beschäftigt ist und mit dieser Karte in der Hand und mit offenem Mund ist sie erschossen worden. Der Todesschrei war noch nicht richtig aus ihrem Gesicht und der offene Mund, der letzte Geschrei...man soll nicht vergessen. Dann sind wir gekommen und wir haben gesehen ganz verschiedene Szenen, die gar nicht zu beschreiben sind, weil das könnte lange Stunden dauern. Die jüdische Polizei hat zusammen genommen die Leichen, die wir noch gesehen zur Arbeit gesehen haben. Die Strassen waren voll von Blut.
David Boder: Was heißt von Leichen, die sie gesehen haben oder von Menschen, die Sie noch gesehen haben?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Mit Leichen von Menschen, [unverständlich] die hat man geschossen. Alle Freunde, die, die man auf den Platz, das heißt...das heißt, der Platz heißt, hm, habe ich schon vergessen...
David Boder: Ah hm, bitte weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Der Platz, das war eine Nebenschleiße, der zu der Bahn führte—dort hat man alle Transporte nach Treblinka geschickt.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also...
David Boder: Wo ist Treblinka?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Treblinka ist Ost—Ost West von Warschau.
David Boder: Wie weit ungefähr?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Drei Stunden Zeit.
David Boder: Ah ha. Nächst welcher Stadt ist es?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nächst welcher Stadt,...hm, so...Bialystok, in Richtung Bialystok.
David Boder: Ja, bitte nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. Damals waren schon die ersten Proben von Widerstand im Warschauer Ghetto. Es waren Fälle von Schießerei, aber noch nicht koordiniert. Die Organisationen haben gearbeitet, aber es war noch nicht...die Arbeit war noch nicht koordiniert und die Hilfe von außen war sehr klein. Zweitens—wir haben gewusst alle, dass der Kampf ist verloren. Wir sind der verlorene Posten, der sterben muss. Damals hat man genommen die Kinder, das Kinderhaus—das Kinderhaus, wo der bekannte polnische—jüdische eigentlich, hm, der jüdische Pädagoge hat gearbeitet in...
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . das Kind von Shalom, das ist, hm, das ist seine, hm, wie heißt der, das ist...ich habe den Namen vergessen...
David Boder: Gearbeitet.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. Da hat man genommen die Kinder. Die Art auf welche man hat die Kinder genommen, war auch interessant. Die deutsche SS ist reingekommen und hat den Kindern Schokolade gegeben, damit die Kinder gehen wollen. Die Verwandten von die, dem Kranken..., von dem Kinderhaus ist mit gegangen. Man wollte sogar außen reklamieren einige. Aber diese haben...wollten das nicht annehmen. Sie haben...sie wollten nicht annehmen die nach Heraus-Reklamierung.
David Boder: Was heißt Herausgabe der Kinder.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, die Herausgabe...
David Boder: Der Kinder oder [unverständlich; beide sprechen zugleich]
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Verwaltung. Die Verwaltung von, hm, jüdischen Kinderheim.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . ist mitgegangen. Also damals sind gegangen sehr viele. Viele sind aber doch geblieben. Man hat uns noch gebraucht für Arbeit. Es war noch nicht alles in Ordnung. Dann haben wir noch zwei Monate gearbeitet. Im März ist die letzte Aussiedlung gekommen. Das war am Tag vom jüdischen Fest von Pe...Pesach. Also vor Pesach haben wir eine große Zuteilung bekommen. Das heißt eine höhere Zuteilung, eine Grössere, damit wir ruhiger sein sollen. Und erstens...in der Nacht um zwei (2) Uhr hat man schon signalisiert, ja,...es kommt wieder die Aussiedlung. Das Ghetto umbesetzt mit verschiedenen Mithelfer von Leute SS. Die Auslieferung hat angefangen.
David Boder: Und die Mithelfer waren wer?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ukrainer, Litauer.
David Boder: Und weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und es waren viele Ukrainer von Russland, die auf die Seite von Deutschland übergegangen sind.
David Boder: Nun wollen Sie uns jetzt sagen...
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . jetzt von der Auslieferung selbst...das heißt, dass diese Verbrennung vom Ghetto und der Aufstand im Ghetto...
David Boder: Das haben wir, das wurde...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: . . . beschrieben
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, also weiter...
David Boder: Ja, also nicht , dass es mich nicht interessiert, aber mein Zug geht heute abend...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und ich möchte mehr von Ihnen wissen...
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . von dem Lager.
David Boder: Jetzt wurden Sie ausgeliefert und was hat Ihnen dann passiert?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ausgeliefert nach Majdanek. Der erste Transport während der letzten Aussiedlung ist nach Treblinka gegangen.
David Boder: [In English] It is here...as I said before an interview at the University where I am forced to interview a certain number of students. I therefore have to give them a limited time. That is the first time in my procedure that I am doing it. And I am therefore insisting to get the personal story of Mrs. Tcharnabroda, to skip possibly the very important personal story about the, hm, hm, ghetto and about the transportation to the concentration camp.
David Boder: [In German] Und sie waren in Majdanek?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also die ersten Transporte sind nach Treblinka gegangen. Die Letzten—und ich war in den Letzten sind nach Majdanek gegangen.
David Boder: Und wo war Ihr Mann?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Immer zusammen mit mir, bis nach Majdanek gegangen.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Zuerst sind wir auf dem Flugplatz Lager...
David Boder: Haben Sie Kinder?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein. Zuerst hat man uns gebracht auf den Flugplatz Lager Laskevich, das ist neben Lublin.Auf diesem Flugplatz hat man uns—da hat man die Männer in eine andere Richtung geschickt und uns in eine andere Richtung. Damals habe ich den Mann verloren.
David Boder: Ah hm.
David Boder: Oh. Haben Sie niemals mehr von ihm gehört?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dann hat man uns...
David Boder: Wie hält das gerichtlich und offiziell? Werden Sie als Witwe anerkannt?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Wieso, trotz allem...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Weil später habe ich eine Nachricht gehabt, dass man hat meinen Mann hat Travniki geschickt. Und Travniki hat man vernichtet, so dass kein einziges Zeuge geblieben ist.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dann hat man...am zweiten Tag hat man uns nach Majdanek geführt. Das ist zwei Kilometer auf der Chelmer...auf dem Chelmer Weg, das ist der Weg nach Chelm. Zwei Kilometer auf diesem Weg geführt mit Assistenz von der SS, da heißt auf jede fünf Frauen sind vier SS gegangen mit dem...[lacht etwas]...mit dem Gewehr.
David Boder: Für jede fünf Frauen oder für jede fünf Reihen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Auf fünf Frauen...
David Boder: . . . sind 4 SS gegangen
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . sind vier SS gegangen mit Gewehr.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Wir wussten natürlich nicht wohin wir gehen. Wir haben gedacht, dass gleich in den Ofen.
David Boder: Warum? Haben Sie schon gewusst, dass das passiert?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, dann haben wir schon gewusst davon.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . weil Viele von Treblinka sind schon weg gelaufen.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also dann wir sind hierher gekommen, zuerst war die Badeanstalt. Dann in Badeanstalt hat man eine Selektion durch geführt.
David Boder: Beschreiben Sie das. Wie hatten sie das getan?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das heißt hier kommt ein SS Mann und wir waren ganz nackt...
David Boder: Und dieses war ein Mann—nicht eine Frau?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein Männer—Frauen auch, aber Männer mit Hunden.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und dann hat man uns ganz einfach angeguckt, wie die Tiere—in die Zähne reingeschaut und die Muskeln probiert ganz einfach mit der Hand, und die Hunde haben gebellt...und dann Manche, die älteren Frauen und die Kranken—hat man auf eine Seite geschoben. Diese sind nicht mehr...von Badeanstalt nicht heraus gekommen. Später uns hat man ausgeladen und man hat uns...
David Boder: In der selben Badeanstalt?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, aber dort die Badeanstalt war in zwei Teile eingeteilt. Das war das Alte noch...Krematorium, das Neue war noch nicht fertig. Das haben wir selbst errichtet.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also so sind...diese nicht mehr heraus gekommen. Wir sind dran gekommen in die Badeanstalt auch, wir sind gebadet und dann hat man uns andere Kleider gegeben, alles wurde weg genommen. Ausserdem hat man uns gesagt, wir sollen gar nichts verstecken, weil wir werden gynäkologisch untersucht.
David Boder: Männer haben es getan?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Und [starkes Rauschen des Tonbandes; unverständlich]
Roma Tcharnabroda: Manche Frauen—vor Aufregung—weil sie zum ersten Mal ganz nackt gestanden sind zum Sehen, haben hysterische Anfälle bekommen und haben sehr viel geweint. Aber zwischen uns waren Manche, die haben gesagt: ‚ Wir schämen uns nicht, warum sollen wir uns schämen?’ Also, dann später hat man uns andere Kleider gegeben...
David Boder: Haben sie Ihre Haare abgeschnitten?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein...Lumpen natürlich und man hat uns auf Feld Fünf (5) geschickt. Das ist das bekannte Vernichtungsfeld. Dort waren wir...
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
Roma Tcharnabroda: 1943, März. Also...auf diesem Vernichtungsfeld...die ersten paar Tage was alles ganz herrlich. Man hat uns gesagt, es wird alles gut sein. Und Propaganda gemacht, dass wir nicht in die Ofen rein kommen, sonder wir sind hier zum Arbeiten, und so weiter. Man hat sogar Frauen mit Kinder mit gebracht. Unter die Frauen und Kinder waren zwei (2) Baracken, das ware eine so genannte Quarantäne, Quarantäne. Dort...dann haben wir Bretter( Rauschen—unverständlich).
David Boder: Was?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Bretter—in den Baracken.
David Boder: Zum Schlafen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, in den ersten Tagen war es nicht so schlimm. Dann hat es angefangen. Sie haben einen Befehl bekommen mehr zu schlagen, weil es sterben zu wenig. Das Kontingent von Toten ist zu klein, gleich in den ersten Tagen. Dann hat es angefangen gleich Krankheit von Durchfall. Von dieser Krankheit sind sehr viele gestorben. Warum? Die Jüdinnen durften nicht aufs Revier kommen.
David Boder: Krankenhaus?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Krankenhaus kommen. Für die Jüdinnen gab es nur Eines: Gesunde oder Tote. Kein Revier, keine Kranken...keine Hilfe für die Kranken. Dort waren aber schon Polinnen. Die waren von Warschau, von Pawia, vom Gefängnis—politisch—...und diese haben uns geholfen.
David Boder: Was heißt politische Polen—Gefangene?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Politische—das heißt nicht von der Strasse genommen—ganz einfach, sondern die waren politisch im Gefängnis—im Pawia Gefängnis und wurden später nach Majdanek deportiert. Diese haben uns geholfen. Das heißt, sie haben unseren Kranken Medizin gebracht, das war ganz einfach gestohlen vom Revier und sie haben uns verschiedene Medikamente gegeben. Später hat es angefangen mit der—und es war einen Selektion. Die SS haben wieder Selektion [starkes Rauschen im Tonband; unverständlich] und man hat Manche, die danach wieder in das Lager gekommen haben [unverständlich]
David Boder: Wie wurde das erklärt?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die deutschen Ärzte erklärten das, wie wir gekommen sind—durch die [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband], die Aufregung—und dann weil es keine Männer gab. So erklärten die Ärzte das. Wir konnten gar nichts bemerken, ob das im Essen war oder nicht. Natürlich wir waren auch zu angestrengt von der Reise, dass wir nichts bemerkt haben. Jedenfalls über neunzig (90) Prozent hatten die Periode verloren.
David Boder: Und wie lange hat das gedauert?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Bein Manchen auf immer, bei Manchen ist es, bei mir wieder zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Nach der Befreiung?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, nach der Befreiung. Nach neun (9) oder zehn (10) Monaten. Also in Majdanek, da fängt jede Woche gleich an mit der Selektion. Das heißt, das Thema in Majdanek war ganz klar. Wir waren sechzehn (16) Stunden in der freien Luft. Wir durften nicht während des Tages in die Baracken kommen. Das heißt sogar, wenn es regnet und alles Mögliche, wir dürfen nur draußen sein. Wir dürfen nicht in die Baracken hinein kommen—für sechzehn Stunden—nur 8 Stunden.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . nur 8 Stunden in den Baracken sein.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, ich muss Ihnen noch was erzählen von dem Klima. Das Klima war so, es war windig und dann sonnig und die ganze Sonne hat so gebrannt, so dass die Füße angeschwollen wurden. Und dann auch bei der Selektion hat er nur auf die Füße geschaut, ob sie angeschwollen sind oder nicht, so dass manche, ganz gesunde und starke Frauen, nur weil sie die Füße geschwollen hatten—müssen in die Ofen. Und dann jede Woche genau ging ein ganzer Transport in die Öfen. Der SS Mann ist gestanden und hat Bonbons gegessen. Und mit den Bonbons in dem Mund hat er mit dem Stecken gestiert, diese nach rechts und diese nach links. Und was das geheißen hat, haben wir schon gewusst.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 155 [B] with the interview of Mrs. Roma Tcharna— Tcharnabroda. In spite of...[spool ends abruptly]
David Boder: Munich, September the 24th. We are working...we are working under very great pressure. I am leaving tonight and it’s four o’clock. The Senate of the UNRRA University, the International University of displaced people is expecting that I will attend a short meeting of theirs; and I have here a most interesting interviewee, Ms. Roma Tcharnabroda.
David Boder: [In German] Also weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nach wieder solcher Selektion sind—ein paar hundert Frauen sind verschwunden vom Lager. Am Abend haben wir ein großes Feuer gesehen und am nächsten Tag haben wir den ganzen Tag gespürt den Rauch von verbranntem Fleisch.
David Boder: Wo wurden die verbrannt in den Ofen oder in den Krematorien?
Roma Tcharnabroda: In den Krematorien. Das war noch nicht gänzlich gemacht das Krematorium. Deshalb haben sie vergast in der Badeanstalt und dann haben sie die Leichen auf das Feld gelegt. Dort war ein solcher großer Graben auf dem Feld, fast wie ein Viereck und dort hat man sie verbrannt. Darüber haben wir jede Woche nach der Zeit der Selektion—jede Woche immer gesehen das große viereckige Feuer und dann haben wir gespürt den Rauch von verbranntem Fleisch.
David Boder: Das war in Majdanek?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. Und dann...
David Boder: Wie schreiben Sie Majdanek?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Majdanek—M A Jot D A...das ist bekannt Majdanek.
David Boder: Das weiß ich.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . nek.
David Boder: . . . nek. Bitte weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und dann nach ein paar Tage sind wir als Arbeitskolonne zu dieser Stelle gegangen und haben das, die Asche auf die Felder getragen. Die Felder von Majdanek sind fruchtbar jetzt von der Asche der verbrannten Leute. Dann...es waren zu wenig diese Selektionen. Man musste noch uns eine andere Vorstellung machen und das war das Aufhängen in Majdanek. Sie sagten es sollte sein ein Strafe für Weglaufen. Manche sollten probieren weglaufen—das war auch nicht wahr, weil man konnte sich nicht vorstellen, das überhaupt zu probieren dort
David Boder: Waren dort Frauen und Männer oder?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Frauen, ich spreche von Frauen im Feld.
David Boder: Und man hat Frauen aufgehängt?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also das hat...damals...das war gleich 2 Monate nach...März, April, Mai,...im Mai, da hat man eine Frau gebracht, die wusste nichts. Auf einmal haben wir gesehen, dass in der Mitte...mitten in der Feld etwas steht. Wir wussten gar nicht—eigentlich was soll das bedeuten. Also sie haben diese...wie heißt das?
David Boder: Den Galgen...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Den Galgen aufgerichtet und dazu diese Frau...nur wir sollten zu Appell stehen, denn wir sind alle im Viereck gestanden mit dem Gesicht zu dem Galgen und dann die Frau musste sich selbst den Stuhl holen. Sie hat sich raufgestellt auf den Stuhl und dann hat der SS Mann gefragt, was für einen letzten Wunsch sie hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich stand ganz nahe dabei. Sie hat gesagt, sie hat keinen Wunsch an die Deutschen. Dann hat er gefragt, ob sie bereut ihre Tat. Da hat sie gesagt, sie hat nicht probiert weg zu laufen, weil das Unsinn ist. Aber wenn sie nur eine Möglichkeit gehabt hätte, hätte sie das getan. Sie bereut wirklich gar nichts, weil das Leben hat so wie so keinen Wert und sie stirbt ganz ruhig. Aber dazu, um ihn ins Gesicht zu schlagen, war sie vielleicht zu...schwach. Sie ist ganz ruhig gestorben ohne einen einzigen Geschrei. Die Frau war drei und zwanzig (23) Jahre alt. Dann mussten wir stehen zur Strafe—wofür wissen wir nicht—aber zur Strafe mussten wir stehen und auf die Tote schauen drei (3) Stunden. Wenn der Appell war zu Ende...
David Boder: Wer hat sie aufgehangen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Wer? Ein SS Mann. Er hat...
David Boder: Hat er sie viel gequält?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, er hat nur ihr die Schlinge um den Hals geschlagen und dann mit dem Fuß den Stuhl weg gestoßen.
David Boder: Hat er ihr Gesicht zuerst verdeckt?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, mit offenen Augen ist sie gestorben.
David Boder: Haben Sie gesehen die tote Frau nachher und das Gesicht der toten Frau?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich bin gestanden zwei (2) Stunden danach ihr gegenüber in Entfernung von ungefähr zehn (10) Meter.
David Boder: Wie hat sie ausgesehen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ganz ruhig. Die Hände waren nach unten getroffen und zusammen geballt.
David Boder: Und das Gesicht?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das Gesicht nach unten auch geblickt, das Kinn nach unten und ganz ruhig, als ob man hätte sie...also ganz ruhig, als ob sie schlief.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und wir müssen später stehen einige Stunden und haben geschaut auf die Tote. Wenn der Appell war zu Ende sind wir nicht weg gegangen. Es waren zwanzig tausend (20.000) Frauen damals beim Appell.
David Boder: Zwanzig tausend (20.000)?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Zwanzig tausend (20.000) Frauen—Häftlinge zum Appell.
David Boder: Wieso wissen Sie die Nummer?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Es war...wir haben doch Nummern getragen.
David Boder: Na ja, da waren aber doch nicht alle dort, viele waren doch vernichtet.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, aber wir sind da, wir wissen wie viele...man zählt doch jeden Tag —zählt man doch.
David Boder: Und?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und jeder Block wird gezählt.
David Boder: Und Sie haben gewusst wie viele es waren?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich weiß das genau. Es waren über zwanzig tausend (20.000) damals im Lager. Wir sind alle stehen geblieben—ohne dass wir sie verständigt haben. Wir sind alle für ein paar Minuten stehen geblieben. Die SS hat sogar gesagt, dass wir einen Aufstand [lacht etwas] hier machen wollen. Wir sind nur stehen geblieben, um die Tote zu verehren. Und sogar alle—damals waren schon Freundinnen, Russinnen, Polinnen und Jüdinnen und alle sind stehen geblieben nach dem Appell Ende. Später hat es angefangen...
David Boder: Haben sie keinen Geistlichen gehabt? Keinen Rabbiner?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Wen?
David Boder: . . . um dort der Frau das letzte Geleit zu geben?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ach Gott, die SS erkannte doch keine Geistliche. Diese haben doch runter gerissen von der Polin alle Medallionen und das alles und sie haben gesagt: „Hier braucht man keinen Gott mehr!“
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: „Gott wird Euch so wie so nicht helfen.“
David Boder: Sehen Sie, ich weiß es ja. Aber ich frage es für meine amerikanischen Freunde...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, diese wissen sehr wenig davon [lacht etwas].
David Boder: Bitte weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Interessant—ein Kapitel ist für sich, es gib Quarantande, die Quarantande, wo...
David Boder: Quarantäne.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Quarantäne, die Quarantäne, ja, wo die Frauen mit Kinder waren. Dort waren keine [unverständlich] weil die Kinder konnten doch nicht rauf. Alle Kinder lagen auf dem Fußboden. Wir, wir durften nicht rein, aber wir wollten sehen, was das eigentlich ist. So sind wir manchmal mit der Reinigungskolonne rein gekommen, um Chlorgas aus zu schütten. Also die Kinder lagen auf dem Boden und es war alles voll Dreck, weil die Kinder konnten doch bei Nacht nicht raus gehen und ein Kind passt doch nicht auf. In der Hölle sieht man nicht solche Bilder, wie man dort gesehen hat. Schmutzige, hungrige Kinder, wie Tiere, haben das alle aus gesehen. Und dann einen schönen Morgen hat man alle Kinder mit den, mit den Müttern genommen auf einen Wagen, solche Autos. Die Autos sind gekommen, man hat diese alle genommen—ins Krematorium und es war aus. Dann hat man in die Quarantäne griechische Jüdinnen gebracht—zwei hundert (200) Frauen von Saloniki. Diese hat man von Auschwitz gebracht. Wir konnten sich sehr wenig mit ihnen verständigen, weil sie haben nur Griechisch gesprochen dann.
David Boder: Was?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Sie haben nur Griechisch gesprochen. Manche haben Hebräisch verstanden.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und mit diesen konnte man sich ein bisschen verständigen. Nach einem Monat hat...sind diese auch vom Lager verschwunden. Schluss mit der Quarantäne. Die griechischen zwei hundert (200) Frauen von Saloniki sind in Majdanek umgebracht worden. Dann hat man russische Frauen gebracht, Russische von Smolensk und von Lübeck, von dieser Umgebung. Diese, das war ein Teil...
David Boder: Russische, christliche Frauen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, das war nur ein Teil, die von der Schlacht in Smolensk entkommen sind. Diese sind auch auf Schmelz gegangen.
David Boder: Nun?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Später hat man die Stärksten von zwanzig tausend (20.000) Frauen, die hat man mit Transport weggeschickt. Ich war im ersten Transport, welche man hat in eine Fabrik geschickt. Ich gehörte damals zu den stärksten Frauen und deswegen hat man mich weggeschickt. Auch diese Selektion war schrecklich. Man hat uns angeguckt wie Pferde, die Muskeln angegriffen wie..., die Zähne, alles und noch dazu ganz nackt. Das haben die SS Männer gemacht.
David Boder: Hat man dort einmal eine gynäkologische Untersuchung, hm Examen gemacht für Geld, für Geld oder solche Sachen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Für Geld. Ein paar Frauen hat man damals raus genommen und sie untersucht.
David Boder: Ja und.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja und...
David Boder: Ich meine nicht nur damals bei dieser Angelegenheit...aber im Allgemeinen...haben sie bloß gedroht mit einer...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, damals hat man gemacht...
David Boder: Man hat sie gynäkologisch...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ein Arzt, ein deutscher Arzt in Uniform.
David Boder: Und das heißt, man hat also gesucht nach...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. Ja, ja.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und dann bin ich weg in Arbeitslager—nach Skarzysko-Kamienna. Dort war ein Lager nur für Juden, die in einer Fabrik gearbeitet haben, eine Munitionsfabrik. Die Meisten—das waren schon nicht SS Leute—das heißt, die Bewachung vom Lager hat SS gehabt und Ukrainer, und als Werkschützen haben Ukrainer gearbeitet und dann waren deutschen Meister, nicht SS. Das ist wichtig für deutsche Psyche, dass Leute nicht nur SS hat das alles gemacht, sondern deutsche Leute auch. Jeder kannte den Namen von einem deutschen Meister Krause, weil er von [unverständlich; beide sprechen gleichzeitig]
David Boder: Was war der Name?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Skarzysko-Kamienna [unverständlich]
David Boder: Wissen Sie den Vornamen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein. Krause. Das was das Schrecklichste an der Fabrik. Wenn Krause ist gegangen, dann sind die Maschinen anders gegangen [lacht etwas] sogar. Er konnte Frauen...manchmal ist er besoffen gekommen sogar, und paar Frauen raus nehmen und diese vergewaltigen, die man später erschossen hat, weil...damit keine Rassenschande ist.
David Boder: Ja. [unverständlich; beide sprechen gleichzeitig]
Roma Tcharnabroda: Es war ein bekannte SS Waffenschlager...Waffens...schlager. Der hat das Selbe gemacht. Der Bruder von solche einer vergewaltigten und toten Frau lebt hier in Deutschland.
David Boder: Ich möchte im Allgemeinen wissen...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und da noch eine Sache—Interessante. Dort war eine Arbeit bei Latrin, die gelbe Arbeit sogenannt. Bei der gelben Arbeit auf der Fabrik sind die Leute zum Tode gegangen.
David Boder: Was für eine Arbeit war das?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Bei Latrin.
David Boder: Ah, bei Latrin?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Latrin, ja. Wenn man...man muss Schutzmittel hier übernehmen, weil man sonst geht man zu Grunde. Und bei dieser...bei dieser Latrin haben die Juden gearbeitet und sie sind zu Grunde gegangen in einigen Monaten. Wenn sie waren schon ganz krank, hat man sie hin geführt...irgendwo in den Wald geführt und dort hat man sie vernichtet.
David Boder: Ich wollte eine Frage fragen; also im Allgemeinen, wie weit haben die Frauen gelitten von den Sachen wie vergewaltigen und anderen Advancen von den Bewach...von der Bewachung?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das war eigentlich verboten, aber das hat nur so ausgesehen. Zum Beispiel, aus Majdanek die schönsten Frauen sind verschwunden
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und dann von Skarzysko hat man uns nach [unverständlich; hört sich an wie Zyrstowa] gebracht, auch eine Munitionsfabrik. In [unverständlich; hört sich an wie Zyrstowa] hat sich das Schlagen bei der Arbeit wiederholt. Diese Schläge waren so, dass manche sind von Hunger gestorben. Am meisten haben gelitten die Leute von Majdanek. Von fünf hundert (500) die von Majdanik nach Skarzysko und nach [unverständlich; hört sich an wie Zyrstowa] gekommen sind, sind sehr wenig geblieben. Von zwanzig tausend (20.000) Frauen von Majdanek sind hier, hier—wie ich schätzen kann—ungefähr fünfzig (50) geblieben. Dann von [unverständlich; hört sich an wie Zyrstowa oder dieses Mal etwas mehr wie Cherstowa] hat man uns nach Deutschland wieder geschickt, wenn die, wenn die Russen nahe gekommen sind. Zuerst—ich war im ersten Transport. Die Anderen sind schon zurück geblieben, weil sie konnten sie nicht mehr weg [unverständlich]. Ich bin nach Ravensbrück gekommen. In Ravensbrück was das Lager vorbereitet für ungefähr drei tausend (3.000) Personen. Später am Ende 1945, nein 1944 und am Anfang 1945 waren über sechzehn...über sechzig tausend (60.000) Leute. Ich kann genau die Zahl nicht geben. Alle Transporte von...von Osten hat man nach Ravensbrück geschickt. Also die Bedingungen waren schrecklich. 4 Leute auf einer Pritsche. Läuse und Verpflegung schrecklich. Ich hab gearbeitet beim Holzhauen. Beim Holzhauen habe ich mir die Beine erfroren
David Boder: In welchem Jahr?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Am Anfang 19...im Januar 1945.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die SS Frau hat gesehen, dass ich gehe ohne Strümpfe. Und wenn ich habe einmal gemeldet, dass ich kann im Walde nicht arbeiten, habe ich fünf und zwanzig (.25 )bekommen
David Boder: Was heißt das?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Fünf und zwanzig (25) Schläge auf den nackten Rücken bekommen.
David Boder: Und wann ist das passiert? Gleich, wie Sie gesagt haben?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, gleich.
David Boder: Nicht beim Appell.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nicht beim Appell—gleich.
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen die fünf und zwanzig (25) Schläge gegeben?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Eine SS Frau.
David Boder: Eine Andere, nicht dieselbe, die es gesagt hat.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Selbe, die Selbe.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das lassen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Was heißt lassen [lacht]...lassen, was heißt lassen? [lacht] Wie stellen Sie sich vor—das lassen! [lacht]
David Boder: Well, dann.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Im Lager gibt’s kein Widerstand mehr. Wegen Widerstand können wir nur vom Warschauer Ghetto sprechen, aber nicht hier.
David Boder: Hat man Sie angehalten?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Natürlich. Man hat mich niedergelegt und man hat mich...und man hat mir gegeben fünf und zwanzig (25).
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Davon habe ich noch jetzt eine ganz große Narbe.
David Boder: Womit hat man Sie geschlagen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Mit einer Pferdepeitsche.
David Boder: So.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dann...dann bin ich schon krank geworden, aber ich bin weiter zu der Arbeit im Walde gegangen. Dort hab ich gearbeitet einige Monate und hab mir die Beine erfroren. Wenn die Amerikaner sind schon näher gekommen, hat man uns von Ravensbrück in die Richtung von Dachau geschickt.
David Boder: Zu Fuß oder mit...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein mit den Wagen.
David Boder: In, in Autos?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, in geschlossene Pferdewagen.
David Boder: Oh ja, bei Zug, bei Eisenbahn...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. Und acht (8) Tage haben wir gar nichts bekommen. Das heißt, sogar kein Wasser.
David Boder: Also, sagen Sie mir, wie lebt man acht (8) Tage ohne Wasser?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das ist interessant. Eben...ihr könnt Euch nicht vorstellen wieviel ein Mensch aushalten könnte...kann. Das wissen wir! [Pause] Acht Tage ohne Wasser. Wir haben am Ende—das war in der Nähen von Bayreuth—haben wir beschlossen...es waren schon viele Tote...von Hunger...und von...natürlich von matt sein...haben wir beschlossen zu klopfen. Und sollen sie schießen. Und wir haben so geklopft, dass sie haben gefürchtet wir werden das brechen, das Ganze kaputt machen, den Wagen.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Wie haben gedroht: „Wir werden schießen“ und wir haben gesagt: „Schießt!“. Also damals haben sie, haben sie gebracht vom Roten Kreuz Gruppe und haben gesagt: „Kinder, wir wollen Euch doch helfen, warum seid Ihr so unruhig?“ Dann sind wir...
David Boder: Das war das Rote Kreuz?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, die SS. Da waren wir Kinder, denn sie haben schon gesehen mit uns geht’s nicht so leicht. Und dann sind wir weiter gefahren und wir sind nach Burgau gekommen, eine Filiale von Dachau.
David Boder: Nicht weit von Dachau.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Eine Filile von Dachau...
David Boder: Filiale.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, Filiale von Dachau.
David Boder: Und sie sagen nicht ganz weit von Dachau.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich orientiere mich nicht, weil ich fahre jetzt nicht weg, wegen meine amputierten Bein. Dorthin sind wir gekommen, das war noch ganz kalt in weißen Mänteln—ohne Wäsche.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit weißen Mänteln?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Solche...na, wie heißt das schnell...
David Boder: Baumwolle?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nicht Baumwolle, solche Staubmäntel.
David Boder: Ah, Staubmäntel!
Roma Tcharnabroda: Solche Mäntel hat man uns gegeben, ohne Strümpfe, wenn man Einem Strümpfe gegeben hat, dann war Einer gelb und Einer schwarz. Und wenn wir sind gekommen haben wir so schrecklich ausgesehen, dass die Meister von der Fabrik Messerschmidt, die gekommen sind, um uns zu sehen und von uns Einige zur Arbeit zu nehmen, haben gesagt offen: „Das ist Schweinerei!“ Und dann waren wir in Burgau. In Burgau sollten fünf hundert (500) Personen sein, dann hat man noch einen Transport geschickt und es waren schon tausend (1.000) Frauen. Und es hat angefangen mit Fleckfieber. Von Fleckfieber sind sehr viele Frauen gestorben. Am meisten haben die ungarischen Jüdinnen gelitten—von Fleckfieber und von Durchfall. Die Läuse waren so schrecklich verbreitet, dass man konnte es nicht aushalten. Dann bin ich krank...von Fleckfieber krank geworden und mit...damit hat angefangen mit den Beinen. Ich konnte schon nicht mehr aufstehen. Von Burgau hat man uns nach Kirchheim geschickt.
David Boder: Und wie hat man sie geschickt? Sie...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Man hat mich getragen, die Häftlinge haben mich getragen—nach Kirchheim. Und von Kirchheim...ich war schon gänzlich krank, die Beine waren schon schwarz...hat man mich ins Lager-Revier, Lager vier (4) geschickt, neben Landsberg. Das bekannte Lager-Revier, wo Tausende, mehr wie tausende Leute gestorben sind vom Fleckfieber.
David Boder: Das ist ja nicht weit von hier.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, nicht weit—Landsberg.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dort habe ich—dort habe ich angefangen schon zu eitern und...man konnte mir gar nicht helfen. Die Ärzte sind gekommen, haben mir natürlich gar nichts gesagt, aber ich habe gesehen, es ist Schluss. Dann Evakuierung vom Lager. Wer gehen konnte, ihn hat man fort gejagt. Ich konnte natürlich nicht mehr aufstehen. Der erste SS Mann ist gekommen und hat einen Pferdewagen gebracht. Ich habe ihm gesagt damals: „Erschießen sie mich.“ Hat er gesagt: „Nein, Kind, jetzt wirst Du leben, ich werde aufgehängt werden.“
David Boder: Warum—hat er das schon gewusst?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Er hat gewusst, dass die Amerikaner nahe kommen. Und dies ist...ist interessant eben von der SS. Wenn jemand sie wirklich bittet um den Tod, dann musst du leben. Aber wenn du leben willst...dann musst Du sterben.
David Boder: Nun?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und weil ich eben gesagt habe—ganz gleichgültig—ich möcht sterben, dann sagt er, Du musst leben. Dann hat man mich wieder in ein anderes Lager—Lager Eins—gebracht und im Lager Eins wurde ich von den Amerikanern befreit. An dem letzten Tag vor der Befreiung—die SS ist weg gelaufen und wir sind geblieben. Die Front ist über unser Lager gegangen. Auf der einen Seite waren die Deutschen, auf der anderen Seite waren die Amerikaner und die haben sich gegenseitig beschossen. Diese, die raus laufen konnten sind raus gelaufen, ich musste liegen. Dann, per Zufall, sind die Barracken von der SS angezündet worden, die daneben standen. Und damals habe ich gedacht, dass man hat die Barracken von uns angezündet. Alle—wer noch mit den Füßen rutschen konnte, sind raus gelaufen. Ich wusste nicht, was zu tun, weil so ein Tod im...
David Boder: Feuer.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . im Feuer wollte ich nicht. Dann habe ich alle Decken herunter geschmissen und ich hab mich selbst herunter geschmissen von der Pritsche. Und so habe ich heraus gerutscht, es war...
David Boder: Was es eine hohe Pritsche oder eine Niedere?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, es war schon solche Erde-Baracken...
David Boder: Ja, was für welche?
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . in der Erde gebaut, ganz tief in der Erde....
David Boder: Oh.
Roma Tcharnabroda: So wie für Hunde. Und das war—es war nach dem Regen, ich bin heraus gerutscht und es war nach dem Regen. Ich habe keine gute Bandage gehabt, nur als Verband gehabt nur solche aus Papier und der Regen und der Schmutz und da alles ist rein und damals ist zu Ende und ist alles kaputt gegangen.
David Boder: Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Zwei Tage nach der Befreiung haben mich die Amerikaner hier in das deutsche Krankenhaus gebracht und die Ärzte haben gesagt, ich werde nur zehn (10) Tage älter. Aber ich habe ihnen gesagt, dass ich werde zehn (10) Operationen aushalten. Und ich habe ausgehalten, trotzdem, dass ich habe diese Schläge—habe bekommen und dann beim Liegen—dass diese Stelle war nicht ganz, hm, ganz, hm, na...
David Boder: Nicht ganz geheilt.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . ja, nicht ganz geheilt und durch das Liegen hat sich das aufgerieben und ich habe einen Dekubitus bekommen und ein Loch—ist noch heute die Narbe so gross. Und ich habe drei (3) Operationen ausgehalten—drei (3) Amputationen hab ich ausgehalten.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gesagt, ein Dekubitus?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dekubitus, das ist die Narbe, hier das sehe...
David Boder: Weiter. Haben sie die Operation unter Chloroform gemacht?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Und?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Die Ärzte haben festgestellt, dass ich werde in zehn (10) Tagen sterben.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Zwei und dreißig (32) Kilo hab ich gehabt nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Was wiegen Sie jetzt?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Jetzt [lacht] ungefähr über 60. Ich bin einen Meter vier und sechzig (1,64) gross und 32 Kilo hab ich gehabt.
David Boder: Hm.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und trotzdem habe ich ausgehalten. Nach der Befreiung sind auch noch sehr viele gestorben—von Durchfall. Weil sie haben angefangen zu essen. Es war doch schrecklich, man hat zum ersten Mal das Essen gesehen.
David Boder: In welchem Lager war das eigentlich?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Was?
David Boder: In welchem Lager war das? In Landsberg?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das war in dem Lager, Lager Eins am Ende war ich.
David Boder: Aber Sie waren im Spital in Landsberg.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, zuerst war ich in Holzhausen. Dort hat man mich sehr gut gepflegt. Und von Holzhausen nach Landsberg und von Landsberg nach Schwabing in München.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie Ihre Füße verloren?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Unterschenkel, zwanzig (20) Zentimeter unter der Knie. Hier, hier.
David Boder: Zwanzig (20) Zentimeter unter dem Knie. Nun.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das heißt Unterschenkel-Amputation.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Beide sind weg, ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Und jetzt gehe ich ganz gut, trotzdem dass die Deutschen gesagt haben, dass ich nicht gehen werde können.
David Boder: Und was machen Sie jetzt an der Universität?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich studiere Pharmazie.
David Boder: Ja. Und wie geht es hier?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich bin sehr zufrieden mit der Universität. Die Professoren sind sehr gut zu uns und sind so freundlich. Das Zusammenleben von den Professoren und Schülern ist viel—ist so gross, wirklich—man kann das an keiner einzigen Universität finden.
David Boder: Und wie vertragen sich die Schüler?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Sehr gut. Es ist interessant, dass man hat gesehen, man kann doch zusammen leben und wenn ein Mensch wie ein Mensch lebt, dann spielt die Nationalität keine Rolle. Wichtig ist der Mensch nicht die Nation.
David Boder: Haben Sie Verwandte in Amerika?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Schreiben sie Ihnen?
David Boder: Wo leben die?
Roma Tcharnabroda: In Chicago. Ich habe ein Affidavit von Chicago bekommen.
David Boder: Ich bin von Chicago. Kann ich sie aufsuchen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja. [lacht etwas]
David Boder: Wie heißen die?
Roma Tcharnabroda: LaSalle Street—Hellberg.
David Boder: Schreiben Sie die Adresse auf.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ich bring es gleich.
David Boder: Sofort. Wie heißen die?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Hellberg.
David Boder: Hellberg. Der erste Name?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Charles Hellberg.
David Boder: Was?
David Boder: Charles?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Charles. Und das ist ein Büro on LaSalle Street
David Boder: Was ist die Profession?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Da weiß ich nichts darüber.
David Boder: Ja, ist das sein Büro dort?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Welche Nummer on LaSalle?
Roma Tcharnabroda: LaSalle North, zwei hundert vier und zwanzig (224).
David Boder: 225?
Roma Tcharnabroda: 24.
David Boder: 224 LaSalle North
Roma Tcharnabroda: North LaSalle Street.
David Boder: Na, ich werde den Mann in zwei (2) Wochen sehen.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, das wäre sehr...
David Boder: Wer ist [unverständlich] Familie...
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, sie müssen sagen, dass ich das Affidavit bekommen habe.
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: [lacht etwas] Aber ich muss auf die Quote warten. Und zwei Beine reichen doch nicht bevorzugt zu sein.
David Boder: Also wie viele...also unter welcher Quote kommen Sie—Polnische?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Auf die polnische Quote und die ist voll. Wahrscheinlich kann ich—muss ich noch ein (1) Jahr warten. Und wenn die UNRRA damals nicht mehr arbeitet, dann hab ich nichts...
David Boder: Oh, wir werden das durch die NIAS machen. Ich werde das selber arrangieren.
Roma Tcharnabroda: [lacht etwas] Ja. Das hat man mir gesagt, dass die Quote ist sehr gross und ich kann nicht rüber kommen.
David Boder: Hm, und der Name ist Charles Helberg.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Und sie wissen nicht was sein Geschäft ist.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein.
David Boder: Und was ist er von Ihnen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Das ist der Onkel von meiner Mutter. Er interessiert sich sehr und er will von Anfang mir helfen, aber er hat keine Möglichkeiten...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie er hat keine Möglichkeiten—kein Geld.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, es ist nicht das Geld. Aber was kann er mir helfen [murmelt—sehr leise—unverständlich].
David Boder: Sie haben was?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Hier ich keine...aber ich habe UNRRA Verpflegung und...
David Boder: Schickt er Ihnen Pakete?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein, weil er kann nichts schicken. Er hat mir ein paar Mal geschickt, aber ich habe nichts bekommen.
David Boder: Hm. Also ist das alles, was Sie uns sagen wollen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja, das ist alles was ich sagen will...
David Boder: Und was wollen Sie amerikanischen Studenten sagen?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Also [lacht] was will ich amerikanischen Studenten sagen? Will ich sagen, wir haben sehr viel gelernt. Wir sind doch nicht pessimistisch. Das heißt wir haben kennengelernt, dass es gibt nur...
David Boder: Ja.
Roma Tcharnabroda: . . . nur eine Wirklichkeit. Die Wirklichkeit des Bösen, aber trotzdem sind wir nicht Pessimisten. Wir haben noch kennengelernt, dass die Möglichkeit der menschlichen Seele ist sehr gross. Man hat...man kann sehr viel aushalten [lacht etwas]. Und das sagt ein Mensch, der auf zwei (2) Prothesen herum lauft. Das Leben ist interessanter wie der Tod—vielleicht nicht leichter.
David Boder: Wie alt sind Sie?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Dreißig (30).
David Boder: Ich werden den Mann aufsuchen—Charles Helberger?
Roma Tcharnabroda: Helberg.
David Boder: Helberg. 224 LaSalle Street.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Ja.
David Boder: Chicago. Und Sie wissen nicht, was seine Beschäftigung ist.
Roma Tcharnabroda: Nein.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the most interesting spool, number 155 at the UNRRA University. [Pause. Knocking sound.] These knocks are the knocks of the artificial legs of the young girl, who just talked to me, and she is now leaving the room.